you're still here and you get another
chance this day to do better and be
better and then what I do I smile I
smile I smile and revel at the
opportunity and challenge in front of me
and the energy of gratitude can really
open you up to this incredible capacity
to feel more energized to feel more
happy rise and shine it's expresso time
what's up believe nation it's evan my
one word is believe and i believe in you
i believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that i want to see exploded
onto the world so let's start your day
off right together grab your cup of
coffee and sip on today's message say
thank you over to you Oprah Winfrey
[Music]
close your eyes for a moment will you
please and breathe with me just close
your eyes and if you will put your thumb
to your middle finger and gather your
other fingers around and let's feel the
vibration and pulse of your personal
energy as you take three deep breaths
with me inhale and as you exhale just
feel the vibration energy blood
pulsating through your body through you
and another inhale
and another inhale and keep your eyes
closed and let's just think about this
day this day that you have been graced
to breathe in and out thousands of times
this day where many of those breasts
were taken for granted you just expected
the next one to come but the truth is
there's no guarantee that the next one
comes this day how you started your day
what your thoughts were this morning how
you've carried yourself through this day
how you've been allowed to have
encounters and experiences some
challenging some more life enhancing
that pushed you forward another day of
being here on the planet Earth as a
human being I just think about that
after all you've been through and this
day alone and the many days and years
passed how you got here to this
prestigious esteemed University the
choices you made that have brought you
to this day
open your heart and quietly to yourself
say the only prayer that's ever needed
thank you thank you thank you you're
still here and you get another chance
this day to do better and be better
another chance to become more of who you
were created and what you were created
to fulfill thank you what you say thank
you to will ultimately determine your
happiness as a human being I just
believe that I think gratitude is so
important I think too often it's really
easy to say thank you for all the things
that are easy to say thank you too but
when something goes wrong when you get
dealt a negative hand when you have a
blowback that happens in your life or in
your business how do you say thank you
to that and if you're constantly only
happy when good things are happening to
you then you're really never gonna be
happy that often when you can understand
that every situation that's happening
around you right now is actually good
can be good if you decide that it's
gonna be good that's when the real world
starts to happen I look at myself and
one of the things that I'm really trying
to pay attention to and work on is not
so much saying thank you but it's an
equivalent of it it's when there's a
challenge in my life or my business
we've I've lost a big client if
something happens on my youtube channel
if somebody leaves a team if I only had
a couple hours sleep you know there's
something that just is negative and that
everybody in the world would give you
you know a pass will give you a pardon
to say you know what it's okay
that's the crappy situation that you're
going through it's okay to complain to
be angry and upset what I try to do in
those that you
questions as I say this is my chance
this is my chance to show myself and to
show the world what I'm made of because
it's easy to win when it's easy but
that's not when you grow you grow
through the difficulties you grow
through the hard times you go through
the challenges and so I don't seek out
those crazy obstacles you know I would
love to have a regular eight hours sleep
every night and for a good chunk of
nights I do but if I'm up but I only
have three hours sleep what am I gonna
do with that day am I'm just gonna mail
it in and I'm just gonna complain I'm
just gonna be upset if I lose a client
or something happens on YouTube I'm just
gonna pack it in for the day and start
again tomorrow I use it what the
internal dialogue inside here this is
what's happening
I tell myself this is my opportunity to
show myself in the world what I made of
today this is my opportunity to grow and
then what I do I smile I smile I smile
and revel at the opportunity and
challenge in front of me because you do
not grow you do not get better you do
not improve by racing against
three-year-olds you improve when there's
adversities you grow stronger through
the struggle the struggle is going to be
guaranteed the results may not be you
may not get to where you want to go you
may not achieve your goal but the
struggle is guaranteed and so if you
know the struggle is guaranteed what's
your mindset gonna be when the struggle
comes when the self-doubt comes when the
negativity comes when the hatred comes
when the failures come what's your
mindset gonna be because the faster you
can get to the point of thank you of
gratitude of I'm gonna learn from this
of this is a positive of this is gonna
make me better stronger healthier
happier from every negative situation
the faster you can get to that point
where you can genuinely say thank you
and even I think at the beginning just
forcing it forcing yourself to lock out
of that negative situation and say how
can I be grateful for this how can I say
thank you for this it immediately moves
you to a more positive mindset
it immediately moves you to a solution
oriented mindset it immediately moves
you closer towards achieving the goal
conquering that mountain going for what
you want as opposed to lying in bed
under the sheets feeling sorry for
yourself now I've got a very special
bonus clip for you but before getting to
that I want to know from you what is one
recent negative thing that has happened
in your life or your business that you
now want to say thank you to because
it's your chance to show yourself in the
world what you're made of leave in the
comments below really curious to find
out thank you guys so much for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon and enjoy the bonus clips
[Music]
the next phase here is also to become
grateful for what it is that you do have
so if you're starting to try to create
change in your life you want to make
sure that you're really focusing on what
it is that you do have in your life so
that you feel an energy of gratitude and
an energy of gratitude can really open
you up to this incredible capacity to
feel more energized to feel more happy
in any given moment where you feel like
oh I don't have what I need or I'm not
supported or things aren't working out
the simple step here is to just say I am
grateful for what I do have and let me
look at me say I'm grateful for what I
do have we create more of what we want
and the energy of gratitude opens our
heart and it expands our energy and it
makes us a much more wonderful loving
person to be around and with that loving
energy we begin to attract more into our
life and so we want to really make sure
that that energy of gratitude is a very
pinnacle part of this group this miracle
worker process which is that we stay
committed and open to what it is that we
are here to receive and we stay
committed and grateful for what it is
that we have and so you can begin today
just by making a gratitude list and
focus on it in there's so many moments
when I think oh my god I can't believe I
have to do this or I can't prove that to
get to that and and then I just think
about what I'm grateful for and it just
spins me immediately out of the crazy
chaos and back into a centered place of
love and so I think that this is a
really valuable tool for you to begin to
use regularly and it's an active tool
throughout the book make us miracles the
most important word ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon
they believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details